[phone ringing]
Hello, this is Gavin.
(Colin)
Hi, Gavin, my name
is Colin Valenti.
I'm calling from
Master Travel Incorporated
to tell you about an exciting
limited-time offer,
exclusive Las Vegas getaway.
Can I have a few moments
of your time
to tell you
about this new package?
You know what,
I would love to,
but I just don't have the time.
[phone beeps]
Hello?
[disconnect tone]
Hm.
[touch tones beeping]
[line trilling]
[phone ringing]
(Colin)
This is Colin Valenti,
Master Travel Incorporated.
How may I be of service?
Hi, Colin Valenti.
My name is Gavin.
I think we just talked.
Did we get disconnected?
(Colin)
Yeah, no--I mean, yeah,
I hung up on you.
Why would you do that?
I mean, are you even--
Are you even allowed
to do that?
(Colin)
Were you going to buy
the Las Vegas package?
Well, I mean, probably not,
but that's not the point.
(Gavin)
The point is--
[phone beeps]
What the hell?
[touch tones beeping]
[line trilling]
(Colin)
This is Colin--
Yeah, Valenti.
Listen.
(Gavin)
I don't know what
crawled up your ass
and set up shop there,
but you don't get to hang up--
[phone beeps]
[gasps]
What?
Oh, my g--
[line trilling]
[phone ringing]
(Colin)
What the [bleep] do you want?
What is your deal, huh?
(Colin)
Um, you don't want
the Vegas package,
so I don't want to talk.
I did us a favor,
wasting our time here.
(Gavin)
Stop, stop, don't you dare
hang up that [bleep] phone,
okay?
(Colin)
Why shouldn't I?
Why shou--
What if I wanted
the Vegas package?
Wha--you know what?
I want the Vegas package.
(Colin)
Sure you do.
[phone beeps]
What?
You mother[bleep]!
Oh, my God!
You son of a bitch.
[line trilling]
(Colin)
Come on, man, let it go.
[bleep] you, man!
[bleep] you!
I want five [bleep] packages!
Right now--you know what?
(Gavin)
You know what?
Where's my wallet?
This is my credit card
number, right here.
Okay, listen.
Get [bleep] off me.
My credit card number
is 0074-5403-0098.
The expiration date
is 12-20!
And then--and then the--
oh, yeah!
The security number is 084!
So run the damn card right now!
Right [bleep] now!
You run it right [bleep] now,
asshole!
[suspenseful music]
(Colin)
Thank you for your business.
Well, I hope
you learned your le--
[phone beeps]
[gasps]
[screaming]
These new call scripts
are really great.
Yeah, I know, right?
[phone rings]
What the [bleep]
do you want, Kathy?